si vemos los puntos de ebullición del
etanol y del dimetil éter podemos ver
que hay una gran diferencia entre ambos
el etanol tiene un punto de ebullición
mucho mayor
78 grados celsius mientras que el de
dimetil éter es de menos 25 grados esto
explica el estado de la materia de estas
moléculas el etanol dado que su punto de
ebullición es mayor que la temperatura
ambiente es líquido a temperatura y
presión ambiental mientras que el
dimetil éter con un punto de ebullición
mucho menor estaría en estado gaseoso
podemos explicar los estados de la
materia observando las fuerzas internos
leku lares que están presentes en estas
moléculas
si pienso en una molécula de etanol
yo sé que el enlace entre oxígeno e
hidrógeno está polarizado sé que el
oxígeno es más electro negativo por lo
que sería parcialmente negativo y el
hidrógeno sería parcialmente positivo ya
que pierde algo de densidad electrónica
si esa molécula de etanol interactúa
con otra molécula de etanol la segunda
molécula de etanol estaría polarizada
también el oxígeno es parcialmente
negativo y el hidrógeno es parcialmente
positivo y sabemos que las cargas
opuestas se atraen por lo que el
hidrógeno cargado parcialmente positivo
es atraído al oxígeno cargado
parcialmente negativo así
habrá atracción entre estas dos
moléculas y a esto lo llamamos enlace
inter molecular por
fuente
hidrógeno
el tipo de enlace inter molecular más
fuerte hay puentes de hidrógeno
presentes entre las moléculas de etanol
y esto explica su alto punto de
ebullición veamos los puentes de
hidrógeno más detalladamente
los puentes de hidrógeno se forman
cuando hay un hidrógeno unido a un átomo
electro negativo como sería el oxígeno
pero los estudiantes olvidan que también
se necesita otro átomo electro negativo
de este lado para tener para tener más
diferencia entre las cargas y hacer que
ese hidrógeno tenga mayor carga parcial
positiva entonces hay tres átomos
involucrados en la formación de puentes
de hidrógeno
pasemos ahora al dimetil éter y veamos
por qué no forma puentes de hidrógeno
si dibujará una molécula de dimetil éter
aquí y pensar en la polarización entre
el oxígeno y este carbono de aquí el
oxígeno es más electro negativo por lo
que sería parcialmente negativo este
carbono sería parcialmente positivo bien
si pienso en la interacción de esa
molécula de dimetil éter con otra
molécula de dimetil éter así
podríamos estar tentados a pensar en la
posibilidad de que haya puentes de
hidrógeno porque sabemos que este
carbono de aquí
tiene hidrógenos unidos a él
entonces algunos estudiantes dirán o
debe haber puentes de hidrógeno entre
este oxígeno de aquí y este hidrógeno
pero ese no es el caso porque este
hidrógeno de aquí aún cuando está
interactuando con un oxígeno este
hidrógeno está unido a un carbono que no
es muy electro negativo por lo que no
hay gran diferencia en electrónica
tividad en el enlace entre carbono e
hidrógeno
aún cuando el carbono es ligeramente más
electro negativo no hay suficiente
diferencia para formar un puente de
hidrógeno solo existe una pequeña
interacción dipolo dipolo entre dos
moléculas de dimetil éter así que en
algún lugar de esta segunda molécula hay
una carga parcial negativa
una carga parcial positiva entonces si
habrá un poco de interacción del polo
dipolo un poco de interacción de polo
d
polo
pero no es muy fuerte y ciertamente no
se acerca a la fuerza del puente de
hidrógeno del lado izquierdo el puente
de hidrógeno siendo la forma más fuerte
de interacción dipolo dipolo entonces el
dimetil eterno tiene un punto de
ebullición tan alto como el etanol y de
nuevo la respuesta es puentes de
hidrógeno
veamos qué ocurre con los puntos de
ebullición de los éter es conforme
aumentamos el número de carbonos en los
grupos al kilo entonces veamos al
dimitir éter de nuevo y lo compararemos
con un éter que tiene más carbonos en el
grupo alquiló el 10 y el éter ya hemos
visto que el punto de ebullición del
dimetil éter es aproximadamente menos 25
grados celsius mientras que el del día
til éter es de 35
grados celsius hay una gran diferencia
entre ambos puntos de ebullición el
punto de ebullición del diet y éter es
apenas mayor que la temperatura ambiente
por lo que es un líquido a temperatura y
presión ambiental veamos si podemos
saber por qué el día y letter tiene un
punto de ebullición mayor
sabemos que las moléculas de éter no
pueden formar puentes de hidrógeno entre
ellas por lo que esa no puede ser la
fuerza interno leku la responsable por
el incremento en el punto de ebullición
si vemos estas dos moléculas de diet y
éter interactuando una de las otras
fuerzas inter moleculares que hemos
visto son las fuerzas de dispersión de
london para más detalles en fuerzas de
dispersión de london puedes ver el vídeo
anterior ahora cuando tenemos grupos
alquilo grandes
estos proveen de un área superficial
mayor para una forma de atracción
llamada dispersión del london y ese
incremento de atracción entre grupos al
kilo implica que es más difícil separar
esas moléculas se requiere de más
energía para separar esas moléculas se
requiere más calor para poder hacerlo y
esa es la razón del incremento en el
punto de ebullición que vemos para el 10
y letter hasta 35 grados celsius y
aunque las fuerzas de dispersión del
london son las fuerzas internos leku
lares más débiles son adictivas por lo
que el efecto es sumado he sumado cuando
tienes montones y montones de moléculas
y esa es la razón por la que hay una
gran diferencia entre el dimetil éter y
el de éter
entonces el incremento en el número de
carbonos en los grupos al kilo aumenta
el punto de ebullición apenas arriba de
la temperatura ambiente pero no
demasiado arriba de la temperatura
ambiente y esto hace del dietil éter un
excelente un excelente solvente para
extracciones
la otra cosa que hacen los grupos al
kilo es incrementar la parte no polar de
la molécula por lo que es un poco más no
polar debido a estos grupos al kilo
de aquí lo que significa que el 17 es
muy bueno disolviendo varios compuestos
orgánicos no polares entonces puedes
disolver muchos compuestos orgánicos no
polares el punto de ebullición se
encuentra apenas arriba de la
temperatura ambiente es un excelente
solvente para extracción porque puedes
disolver varias moléculas orgánicas no
polares y luego puedes simplemente
evaporar el éter quedando solo tu
producto orgánico entonces usarás diet y
letter para muchas extracciones
veamos ahora otro tipo de éter que es
una muy interesante
llamamos a estos tres éter es de corona
si vemos a este determinante de aquí es
llamado un éter de corona este fue
descubierto por una persona llamada
charles peterson quien ganó un premio
nobel por ello y el sistema de
nomenclatura para éter es de corona
sería primero contar cuántos contar
cuántos átomos comprende el anillo o la
corona
entonces contamos 1
11 12 13 14 15 16
hay 18 partes en esta corona por lo que
escribamos
18 aquí así seguido del nombre que probó
na
seguido del número de oxígenos que tenga
entonces tenemos un oxígeno 2
4 5 y 6 por lo que la nomenclatura sería
18 corona
y eso te dice con qué tipo de éter de
corona estás lidiando ahora porque se le
llama éter de corona pues lo interesante
de los seres de corona es que pueden
interactuar con diferentes iones por
ejemplo el tamaño de un millón de
potasio k
más
encaja perfectamente en el centro de
aquí el espacio es perfecto para que un
millón de potasio que hay y dado que
todos estos oxígenos tienen pares de
electrones disponibles están cargados
negativamente existe atracción entre el
guión de potasio cargado positivamente y
los electrones cargados negativamente o
los átomos de oxígeno con carga parcial
negativa
por lo que haya tracción cargas opuestas
se atraen y esas cargas negativas van a
sujetar a lyon potasio aquí de esta
forma por lo que parece una corona si
pensamos en el guión potasio como la
cabeza de alguien y que está usando esta
corona de éter en la cabeza así los
seres de corona han probado ser muy
útiles moléculas muy útiles por ejemplo
si tenemos si tenemos fluoruro de
potasio algo de acá más
efe - normalmente el fluoruro de potasio
no se disolvería en un solvente orgánico
no polar pero si usas un éter de corona
los oxígenos se pueden encargar del
potasio y la parte externa del éter de
corona es no polar entonces esta porción
y esta porción la parte externa del éter
de corona es no
polar
por lo que se disolvería en un solvente
orgánico en un solvente orgánico no
polar como el benceno muy bien similar
disuelve asimilar por lo que esta
porción se disolvería en
ven quién no
y lo que eso haría es que liberaría el
unión flúor
incrementaría la fuerza núcleo física de
la unión flor
que podría participar en una reacción sn
2 entonces ese es uno de los usos de los
seres de corona ir y tomar el camión
dejando que la unión funcione como un
mejor núcleo filo porque el guión
potasio ha sido soltado por el éter de
corona y por supuesto dado que cada ion
tiene un tamaño diferente
se pueden usar éter es de corona de
tamaños diferentes para que se encarguen
de esos guiones pienso que los cetes de
corona son moléculas muy muy
interesantes y si pudiéramos ver una
representación tridimensional de un éter
de corona es mucho más sencillo ver que
la parte externa es muy no polar son
moléculas muy muy interesantes